la ansiedad y el cansancio están en su
punto más alto pero también los
contagios y la crisis económica van en
el mismo sentido se debería priorizar la
economía o proteger la disminución de
contagios
bueno yo creo que la disyuntiva entre
economía y salud es una disyuntiva falsa
tenemos el ejemplo de corea del sur de
singapur de taiwán de tantos países en
el mundo que han llevado a cabo una
mejora de la protección a sus ciudadanos
con muy pocos fallecimientos en un
entorno en el que se ha preservado el
tejido productivo yo creo que el
problema en la unión europea viene de
una falta de coordinación muy importante
entre los países no hay protocolos
simples y sencillos que dar a los
negocios para llevar a cabo su trabajo
día a día y a la vez hay medidas que son
contradictorias entre unos países y
otros entonces hay veces da la sensación
de que no está bien organizado cuando
ves por ejemplo en países como españa o
en italia que se prohíbe que una persona
se mueva de uno
de una ciudad a otra y sin embargo se
puede ir de un país a otro yo creo que
tenemos mucho que aprender de los países
asiáticos qué protocolos serían los
indicados como usted nos menciona de
algunos países que sirven de ejemplo y
cuáles han sido equivocados por ejemplo
estos cierres de negocios pueden hacer
más daño que el mismo kobe 19 generar
más pobreza extrema seguro seguro nos
vamos a encontrar con graves problemas
no solamente económicos sino sanitarios
problemas psicológicos problemas de
depresiones etcétera pero por ejemplo
con los sencillos en los países
asiáticos inmediatamente se han tomado
medidas para que los negocios tengan a
su disposición protocolos que permitan
que se les lleve a cabo su negocio sin
problemas de protocolos de
distanciamiento protocolos de control de
por ejemplo de dar a gel hidroalcohólico
detener la utilización de máscaras
distanciamiento social y organizado de
manera habitual